the media fawn over an evil dictatorship
president Trump presents a budget that
has no fiscal limits whatsoever plus the
worst portraits in human history are
unveiled at the Smithsonian of Barack
and Michelle Obama they're truly
incredible I'm Ben Shapiro is the Ben
Shapiro show
okay I can't wait to show you these for
these portraits because they truly are
amazing if the portraits of Michelle and
Barack Obama Michelle's portrait looks
nothing like Michelle and Barack Obama's
was apparently taken in the Ivy at
Wrigley Field he's legitimately sitting
in the middle of like poison ivy with
flowers in it in a chair it's so weird
and I can't wait to show it to you but
you're gonna have to wait for me to show
it to you because first I want to say
thank you to my sponsors over at helix
sleep so when I travel I don't tend to
sleep as well but one of the reasons for
that is because I don't have my helix
sleep mattress helix sleep offer
something that does not exist anywhere
else a mattress personalized to your
unique preferences and sleeping style
that will not set you back thousands of
dollars you know it's worth spending a
little bit of money for a nice mattress
and you're gonna be spending half your
life on it anyway go to helix sleep comm
slash Bend and take their simple two to
three minutes sleep quiz they build you
a custom mattress that'll be the best
thing you've ever slept on for couples
they even personalize every side of the
mattress well both sides anyway you
don't want eight sides of the mattress
everyone from GQ to Cosmo to the near
attends everybody's talking about how
great helix sleep is because it is we
had a more expensive mattress we got rid
of it because helix sleep is so good it
comes in the mail it is delivered
directly to your door you unpack the box
and then just inflates right in front of
you
because it is foam you try it for a
hundred nights for free if you don't
love it they'll pick it up and refund
you in full right you try it on there
that's what I mean by for free you pay
for it but if you don't like it you can
always ship it right back to them if you
don't love it they will pick you up and
refund it info you're not gonna want to
do that you're gonna want to buy it and
you're gonna want to and you're gonna
want to keep it because it is so good go
to helix sleep comm slash Ben right now
and get 50 bucks towards your custom
mattress that's helix sleep comm slash
Ben right now you get $50 toward your
custom matrix again helix sleep comm
slash Ben they also have other products
that are great as well the helix
mattress protector and the helix
foundation now all of these great
products go over to helix sleep comm
slash Ben right now you get 50 bucks
toward that mattress and it really is a
first-rate mattress I love sleeping on
the helix sleep mattress okay so the the
Olympics were happening over the weekend
and you would think well this would be a
good time to point out that they're
happening in South Korea the Winter
Olympics would be good time to point out
that the South Korea is a wonderful
place and North Korea is to borrow some
language from President Trump a bleep
hole
it is not a nice country it is the worst
country maybe on the face of the earth
between the years in 1994 and 1997
somewhere between 350,000 and 3.4
million million North Koreans died of
servation is about two decades ago in
mass starvation okay they still have
mass Glocks they still in the 1980s had
concentration camps where they would
legitimately torture or murder people
they still do in some places of the
country if you do not do what the regime
wants you to do they will kill you they
they killed the the regime kim
jeong-hoon recently killed his it was
brother-in-law I think that he murdered
I or his uncle I was both actually his
uncle he killed by tossing him to dogs
and his brother-in-law I believe he
murdered in a VX attack he actually used
in weapons of mass destruction in a
public place he's sent an assassin to
basically put a handkerchief filled with
a deadly spore over the guy's face and
killed him outright well that would be
an example of a bad country what is not
an example of a bad country is the
United States and if we're gonna talk
about people who are forwarding the
aspirations of bad countries you don't
actually start with President Trump's
and Jeff Flake who's the senator from
Arizona has been very critical of the
President of the United States because
he says that President Trump has said
ridiculous things about the press I
agree he said the president Trump has
has made overtures to regimes like
Vladimir Putin's which has been true
more in theory than in practice here is
Jeff Flake going after Trump for giving
support to dictators that I'm gonna show
you who actually gives support to
dictators I think the president stops
needs to stop calling Democrats or
Republicans or others who who don't
stand or applaud at every line that he
has that there unamerican he also used
that term or are treasonous words matter
and and when he talks about fake news
for example I gave another speech where
I talked about how that gives aid and
comfort to authoritarians of around the
world who are now labeling their
opposition or dismissing real dissent as
fake news so those things matter okay
the reason that I'm showing this is
because the media there's been the media
line right Chris Cuomo yesterday tweeted
out that the media have been under
assault from President Trump and the
reason people don't trust the media is
because the media have been ripped apart
by the President of the United States
this of course is the typical line is
that dictators all over the world are
taking their cues from President Trump
because President Trump is so unfriendly
of the press okay now let's talk about
why people actually hate the press the
real reason people hate the press is
because the press are a bunch of
sycophants when it comes to some of the
worst dictators on planet earth
not everyone in the press they check
Tapper CNN notably has been ripping
other members of the press for kissing
up to the North Korean regime but the
sister of kim jeong-hoon arrived in
south korea for the olympics and she was
giving some pretty spectacular side I to
Mike Pence and because Mike Pence is
evil as we all know from Ally hates gay
people apparently Mike Pence has to be
given side eye if you don't give my pen
side eye this means that you are a bad
person but if you do give mike pence I
die you can go back home to a regime
that routinely murders thousands of
people that shoots deserters that
attempts to take everyone who tries to
make trade with the outside world and
kills them and the media will just kiss
her ear so here's CNN's headline Kim
Jong Un's sister is stealing the show at
the Winter Olympics why cuz she's there
and she's smiling okay here's another
headline this is all from mainstream
media outlets let's do some more of
these headlines is from The Wall Street
Journal the north korean cheer squads
presence was impossible even for the
skaters to ignore okay we do actually I
believe have some some actual film of
the of the tweet squad do we not so
here's what the tweets of the cheer
squad rather here's what the cheer squad
looked like from North Korea and the
media were just over they were just over
the moon about this this was so glorious
now I want to point something out we've
just had two full years of the media
explaining that Mike Pence and Donald
Trump want to turn women in the United
States as refugees from The Handmaid's
Tale in The Handmaid's Tale women are
forced to rare wear red uniforms
procreated the whim of the dictatorship
and do everything the dictators tell
them to do then
there's the North Korean cheer squad
which wears red uniforms gets pregnant
and has abortions whenever the regime
tells them to we shot if they don't do
exactly what they are supposed to do and
the media cheer them here's what it
looked like in South Korea
okay so there you have it in the media
love the North Korean cheerleading squad
sure if they don't share properly they
get shot in the head back home so that's
excellent but this is something in the
media have always loved they loved the
idea of human beings as cogs in a vast
machine I remember back during the was
it the 2010 Beijing Olympics was a 2010
when they did the Olympics in Beijing I
can't remember now I believe it was and
and when they did that Olympics the
opening ceremonies were thousands of
people marching in unison and and waving
their arms in unison and it truly was an
amazing spectacle and the media was just
excited about it because whenever people
just become little widgets to be
manipulated by the state the media has a
really good time with a particular one
the Marxist dictatorships they're not so
big on non-marxist hunters in South
America for example where they force
people to goose-step but they are very
big on these sorts of displays oh my
goodness look at the coordination look
the magical coordination of all the
people yeah well you know what I've
clapped in time too if they were
threatening to shoot my family back home
if I didn't clap properly and smile
properly for the cameras because of the
yoosh which is what they call the the
the regime in North Korea they have this
this philosophy of yoosh which suggests
that there's a cult of personality
worship for the great leaders in North
Korea here are some more headlines from
the media celebrating all of this of
course so we can go back to we have The
Wall Street Journal this one is from
Reuters I believe amid Olympic date on
spent snubs North Koreans and visit
Pyeongchang oh how Darren Mike Pence
snubbed the North Koreans they supposed
to be nice to the lady he didn't stand
for the North Korean national anthem so
according to the left media it is good
when Americans don't stand for the
national anthem but it is bad when Mike
Pence doesn't stand for the North Korean
national anthem you get that the
American national anthem standing for
the freest country in the history of the
world good when American citizens kneel
for it bad when Mike Pence doesn't stand
for the anthem for a country that is
oppressing millions of his own people 20
million of his own people at current
count okay more headlines from from the
media I mean they're just tons of these
is from Politico
Fred warmbier criticizes North Korean
Olympic spirit how dare
Fred warmbier criticized the North
Korean Olympic spirit oh you mean just
because his son was murdered by the
North Koreans remember otto warmbier he
was the college student who traveled
over to north korea idiotically and then
tried to supposedly steal a poster from
a hotel room and they
we beat him to death I mean they beat
him so badly they by the time he was
returned to his parents at home he died
in the hospital just days later but how
dare Fred warm BR criticized the North
Korean Olympic spirit just terrible just
awful for him to do that and that wasn't
the full extent of the media treatment
here okay this one was but this one was
from BuzzFeed the only decent one was
from BuzzFeed which shows you how crazy
things are saying don't be fooled by
North Korea's Winter Olympics charm
offensive when BuzzFeed is the when
BuzzFeed is the voice of reason
you know something has gone intensely
wrong with the moral fabric inside the
inside the American media and it gets
even worse in just a second I'm gonna
read to you some of the accounts of Kim
Jong loons sister the Worshipful
accounts of Kim Jong loons sister
because it's pretty astonishing we're
gonna get to that in just one second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at stamps Ikon so the post
office is actually great right they get
you all your services all you have to do
is stand in line for a little while but
if you don't have time and you want to
save a little bit money stamps calm is
the best way to do it it's the easiest
way to access all the amazing services
of the post office they never close you
can print postage for letters or
packages at your convenience 24/7 you
can print postage for any mail class
right from your own computer the exact
amounts of postage every time you never
under pay or over pay again they save
you time and money which you can use to
grow your business obviously create your
stamps calm accounts in minutes online
with no equipment to lease and no
long-term commitments click print mail
you're done it is convenient it is
reliable it is efficient and it is very
easy
they bring again all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service
directly to your fingertips we use it
here at the Daily wire offices routinely
we use stamps calm because it means that
we don't have to send our folks over to
the post office every five minutes to
send mail instead we have the scale
right here in the office in right now
you can enjoy the stamps calm service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and the
digital scale it's pretty awesome offer
that stamps calm and you use promo code
Ben you go click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro rather you type in Shapiro at
the top of the homepage when you click
on that microphone at stamps.com and
that means that you get the stamps.com
service with the special offer including
a four week trial plus postage and
digital scale when you go over there and
check it out stamps comm and use that
promo code Shapiro as well so they know
that we sent you and save your business
time and money already so that was not
the extent of the media's
coverage of North Korea so here is the
lead from CNN quote if diplomatic dance
were an event at the Winter Olympics Kim
Jong Un's younger sister would be
favored to win gold with a smile a
handshake and a warm message in South
Korea's presidential guestbook kim
yo-jong has strong accord with the
public just one danes the byung-chan
games i hope young yang and sail get
closer in our people's hearts and move
forward the future of prosperous
unification she said her guestbook
message referring to the capitals of
North and South Korea
by the way I found a nice message if you
think it's a nice message is because you
don't know anything about North Korea
and it's been part of North Korea's
regime it's been part of their stated
goal since literally the first day it
was insipid it was initiated the the
stated goal of North Korea is
reunification of South Korea and North
Korea under the auspices of the Kim
family this has been their goal since
the foundation of the North Korean
regime in 1950 the idea that this was
some sort of overture oh yeah let's get
together and have a republic a federated
Republic nonsense absolute sheer
nonsense the Kim family knows the minute
they break down that wall between North
and South Korea every person in North
Korea rushes into South Korea but listen
I mean listen to this coverage it's just
insane seen by some as her brother's
answer to American 1st daughter Ivanka
Trump Kim at 30 is not only a powerful
member of Kim Jong Un's kitchen cabinet
but also a foil to the perception of
North Korea's antiquated militaristic
that's not a perception they are
antiquated militaristic harrassing those
photos and nighttime from space of North
Korea and South Korea South Korea
completely lit up North Korea completely
dark except for Pyongyang the capital
there's literally one light there which
is probably the presidential palace yeah
I love that they say that she's the
answer to Ivanka Trump last time I
checked it vodka Trump isn't forwarding
the deaths of tens of thousands of
people one day at a time
last I checked for all of the things
people say about Ivanka Trump she isn't
standing up for her evil brother who's
sitting around trying to launch nuclear
weapons at people around the world or
planning to do so just ridiculous they
bury this this paragraph 5 is finally
when when CNN notes that by the way
North Korea might be a bad place as
North Korea's brutal dictator Kim's
brother has ruled with an iron fence
it's coming to power operating Nazi
style prison camps for pressing
political opposition even executing
senior officers and his own family
members in an effort to consolidate
power
but don't worry CNN is there to make
sure that everybody is happy about it
here's Reuters
a prim young woman with a high forehead
and hair half swept back quietly gazes
as the throngs of people pushing for a
glimpse of her a faint smile on her lips
and eyelids low as for bodyguards jostle
around her in her first appearance on
the global stage kim yo-jong the sister
of North Korean leader Kim jong-un had
her every move closely scrutinized
crowds applauded as she stood for the
South Korean anthem during the opening
ceremony for the start of the Winter
Olympic Games while her big smiles and
relaxed manner left a largely positive
impression on the South Korean public my
goodness I mean this is Walter Durant
equality stuff for folks who don't know
Walter Durant who is a reporter for the
New York Times and he famously traveled
in I think was nineteen thirty
thirty-one over to Russia where he
promptly said that everyone in Russia
was doing great there was no starvation
rumors of mass starvation of the whole
um holida Maher in the in the Ukraine or
were vastly overstated and there was
nothing like that happening that was a
lie
tens of millions of people were dying in
mass starvation thanks to the salan
regime the New York Times covered it
that way and he want a Pulitzer Prize
for it which is demonstrative how
corrupt the media are the media were
racing to see who could provide the most
funding coverage of the North Korean
sister here's the Washington Post quote
they marveled at her barely their makeup
and her lack of bling they commented on
her plain black outfits in simple purse
they noted the flower shape clip they
kept her hair back in a no-nonsense
style here she was a political princess
but the North Korean first sister had
none of the hallmarks of power and
wealth that Koreans south of the divide
have come to expect
it looks obsessed South Korea many
twenty-something women list plastic
surgery and brand name bags his life
goals most of all kim yo-jong was an
enigma just like them but nothing like
them a woman with his things like smile
who gave nothing away during her
three-day Olympic related visit to South
Korea as brother kim jongwan special
envoy wow wow i mean the level of
fawning from the washington post there
is so extreme it's crazy I mean that is
just imagine they were eight that about
Eva Braun and you're basically coming
closer to what this actually is but Eva
Braun at the 1936 Olympic Games her
shockingly blonde hair her beautiful
good looks her glamour style my goodness
and just again the media have a certain
love for Marxist dictatorships they
certainly do not have even for even for
out to the American system of government
in some ways they would never recover an
emissary from America
that way if they were to the Foreign
Press I mean this is it's it's pretty
incredible actually there is something
else going on here obviously and that is
that the Trump for the trumpet
ministration is a direct odds with the
North Korean regime and the Trump
derangement syndrome that is arisen in
the media is so crazy that Mike Pence
being in South Korea the Trump
administration being the president I'm
gonna Trump being the president and that
means the enemy of my enemy is my friend
even if that means my enemy the enemy of
my enemy is actually an evil repressive
North Korean dictatorship that
slaughters tens of thousands of its own
people on a regular basis by the way if
you actually want to help if you
actually want to help and do something
about this my friend Bethany Mandel is
big fundraiser for the free North Korean
charity and you can you can help it's
Liberty in North Korea this is one of
the ways that you can actually help
smuggle people out of North Korea she
got over to a Twitter account she offers
ways for people to to escape from North
Korea can offer money it's something
like four hundred dollars helps one
person escape from North Korea and out
to the west that is a worthwhile cause
because this is truly evil if you're in
the media and your life has led you to
the point where you are propping up some
of the worst people on planet earth
because you hate Donald Trump that much
let me suggest that you go back and
repaint your sins it's one of the things
I hate most about politics this friend
of my enemy of my enemy is my friend
nonsense it's just not true I hated it
when it was the Trump campaign doing it
with the alt-right during the campaign I
hate it when it's the American media
doing it with North Korea it's worse
when it's worth critics that's an actual
foreign foe like he all right is
relatively small force in American
politics they've been marginalized I
think at this point despite the original
attempts by the Trump campaign to
integrate them into the Trump campaign I
think they've been marginalized by this
point thank God but I think North Korea
obviously is a major foreign threat and
what they've been doing lately firing
nuclear-tipped missiles or at least by
dropping nuclear bombs in nuclear test
firing long-range missiles right this
stuff is extraordinarily destabilizing
and when the media are cheering them on
it makes the North Korean regime feel
that if they keep up the pressure on the
United States eventually the United
States will grant them more concessions
understand the North Korean economy is
almost entirely dependent on infusions
of foreign capital those infusions of
foreign capital happen because of
blackmail the reason the North Koreans
keep firing off long-range ballistic
missiles is because they want the West
to come to the table and then give them
as a payoff they did this in the 90s
Bill Clinton they did it in the 2000s
with George W Bush they've done it with
the Chinese and now they're trying again
with the West Trump so far has not been
willing to do that which is of course
the right move
we need to starve them out the sanctions
we've placed on them are not nearly
harsh enough Nicholas II burstad has an
excellent column over at commentary
magazine very long piece comprehensive
piece about the the situation in North
Korea what he suggests is that we make
the sanctions significantly harsher on
North Korea that's exactly right
but the fact that the media are granting
all sorts of credibility to a regime
simply because that regime is an
anti-trump is both morally dubious and
ethically astonishing it's truly amazing
I mean the Washington Post slogan is
democracy dies in darkness perhaps the
slogan for the entire media right now
ought to be North Koreans die in
darkness because while they are glowing
about Kim Jong Un's little sister they
are they are willing to do all of that
in order they're ignoring the fate of
the of the people who are being
slaughtered on mass in North Korea it's
just disgusting and horrifying well in
other news there's a situation over at
the White House the situation over the
White House continues to be a relatively
serious of a guard reporter so as you
recall Rob Porter was one of the top
staffers at the White House and Rob
Porter was recently forced to resign
last week was forced to resign after
allegations came out that he had beat
two of his ex-wives not particularly one
who released a picture of herself
with a black eye now the way that a
normal administration would deal with
this is saying we didn't know about it
the problem is that apparently they
didn't know about it apparently Tom
McGann the White House Counsel knew
about it for a year apparently John
Kelly knew about the allegations but
sort of believed Rob Porter it's unclear
what sort of details John Kelly knew the
chief of staff whether he knew full-on
and these were wife-beating allegations
or whether it was just allegations of
spousal emotional abuse for example Rob
Porter had told him that these women
were lying and so Kelly simply believed
him rather than doing the research the
FBI I've been holding up his security
clearance I don't know if Kelly knew
that's why the security clearance had
been held up in any case we reached the
end of last week and President Trump
comes out he's talking about Rob Porter
leaving and he rose his comments on the
situation
we wish him well he worked very hard I
found out about it recently and I was
surprised by it but we certainly wish
him well it's a
obviously tough time for him he did a
very good job when he was in the White
House and we hope he has a wonderful
career and hopefully he will have a
great career ahead of him but it was
very sad when we heard about it and
certainly he's also very sad now he also
as you probably know he says he's
innocent
and I think you have to remember that he
said very strongly yesterday that he's
innocent so you'll have to talk to him
about that but we absolutely wish him
well
hey Trump reiterated this in a tweet
that he tweeted out this over the
weekend
I said people's lives are being
shattered and destroyed by a mere
allegation some are true and some are
false some are old and some are new
there is no recovery for someone falsely
accused a life and career are gone is
there no such thing any longer as due
process if there's a serious problem
with the sweet there's a serious problem
with with Trump's angle which I think
has some serious moral holes in it I'm
gonna discuss all of that in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at policy genius so as
you know February is the shortest month
of the year which makes it difficult to
fit in everything that you want to do
which is why right now before you forget
you should go and you should buy
yourself some life insurance ok there's
one of those things where you put it off
you put it off you put it off and then
boom you're dead and it's too late so
this is why it's important through to
actually go and get the life insurance
that you need policy genius is the
easiest way to compare and buy life
insurance online they let you compare
quotes in just minutes saving you
precious hours of this very short month
and they save you money as well in fact
policy genius is helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance and placed
over 20 billion dollars in coverage and
they don't just insure life they have
health insurance disability insurance
pet insurance renter's insurance so if
you are attempting to fulfill that New
Year Zero New Year's Eve pledge that you
made to make yourself more fiscally
responsible to protect your family don't
waste any more time don't wait for the
month to end go over to policy
genius.com right now no sales pressure
no hassle you get quotes in 5 minutes or
less policy genius calm if you need life
insurance it should not take a lifetime
you get a policy genius calm go get your
life insurance be a responsible person
make sure that your family is taken care
of policy genius.com go and check it out
ok so president Trump makes these
comments about Rob Porter now I know
that there are a lot of people who are
Republicans who are conservatives who
are unhappy with me that I disagree with
the President on this the reason that I
disagree with the presidents on this is
because I am not sitting in a court of
law
hey I am not a jury neither are you if
you think that it is your job to grant
innocence until proven guilty if that is
your job just as a citizen not as a
juror if your job as a citizen is
innocent until proven guilty I don't
want to know why you were chanting lock
her up along with Donald Trump Hillary
Clinton was not indicted or tried for
any crime nor was she convicted of any
crime yet most Republicans feel that
Hillary Clinton committed a crime you
know why cuz she committed a crime she
didn't commit a crime and I can say she
committed a crime you know who else
committed a crime OJ Simpson he was not
convicted of any crime they lost a civil
suit not the same thing as being
convicted of a crime okay there are lots
of people who have committed crimes and
gotten away with it there are lots of
people who should have been indicted who
should have been tried who should have
gone to jail and were not right there
was a restraining order taken out
against Rob Porter police didn't press
charges because the ex-wives apparently
didn't want to press charges but the
idea that simply by declaring your
innocence suddenly you are innocent that
obviously is not true in any real sense
even more than that there's a real
inconsistency to President Trump here
President Trump says you know we need
innocent until proven guilty is the same
guy who said that Barack Obama was born
in Kenya without any evidence and
maintained that for years this is the
same guy who said that Ted Cruz was
ineligible for the presidency and that
Ted Cruz's father was complicit in the
murder of JFK with no evidence this is
the same guy who still says that the
Central Park five are guilty despite DNA
evidence exonerating the Central Park
five my President Trump is not exactly
famous for not jumping to conclusions my
president every time there's a terror
attack President Trump I think rightly
jumps to the conclusion in many cases
that if it looks like an Islamic terror
attack is probably an Islamic terror
attack he doesn't say innocent until
proven guilty in those cases my
President Trump is not famous for
innocence until proven guilty you know
why because in real life you know in in
the non-judicial world innocent until
proven guilty is not the standard the
question is how do you evaluate the
evidence in front of you in this case we
have two ex-wives and an ex-girlfriend
who all testified the Rob Porter is
abusive we have a picture of the ex-wife
with a black eye we have a restraining
order that was taken out and we have
divorce papers in which this stuff was
alleged it is not just women saying
stuff but there's something weird about
you know how president from tweets this
and and how he approaches this president
Trump seems to side with
everybody who's alleged to have sexually
abused someone or sexually assaulted
everyone he sides against everyone who
commits any sort of crime here's a
pattern here
Bill Clinton before Donald Trump was
bringing women to Bill Clinton's into
two debates with Hillary Clinton where
he was bringing one Nia Broderick to do
full-on press events suggesting that
Bill Clinton was a rapist during the
1990s you know who is defending Bill
Clinton from all of these women you know
it was insulting the women Donald Trump
you know who sides with Roy Moore and
does the well he says he's innocent
routine it was Donald Trump who was it
that was siding with Roger Ailes and
saying he didn't believe any of the
allegations about Roger Ailes it was
Donald Trump Bill O'Reilly it was still
Donald Trump my President Trump has a
long Mike Tyson Donald Trump right Mike
Tyson when he was alleged to have
committed rape Donald Trump has said
that he he doesn't think that that
actually happened no president Trump has
a long history of standing by the sides
of men who are accused of sexual assault
and sexual harassment and sexual
allegations and then saying they say
they're innocent therefore they're
innocent but he's never helped the same
standard with regard to any other crime
which I think betrays a hole in the
man's moral character I think that you
already use the same standards of
evidence for any of this stuff whether
you're talking murder or whether you're
talking financial irregularities or
whether you're talking sexual assault
and sexual harassment if someone
provides a credible account with some
supporting evidence then that is enough
to at least say that maybe the guy's
guilty
you're proclaiming innocent there's not
a criminal in prison who doesn't say
he's innocent right this is joke in the
Shawshank Redemption right that
everybody says they're innocent the
reason is because if you are convicted
of a crime of course are gonna maintain
the innocence if you're brought up in
front of a judge of course they're gonna
say the innocent everybody's ever been
accused of anything says that they're
innocent Anthony Weiner says that he was
hacked originally before he admits that
he was sending pictures of his junk to
random women on the internet everyone
says they're innocent Donald and here's
the real key Donald Trump says he's
innocent right Donald Trump has been
accused of sexual assault and sexual
harassment by a multiplicity of women
and he says I'm innocent therefore all
the women are lying so he'd be in a hard
spot if he said Rob Porter is probably
guilty of something cuz then people
would say well you know you have
allegations just like Rob Porter does
why shouldn't we believe the women Trump
has never really had to answer for that
the left keeps trying to get him on that
and this is just the latest iteration of
that that said the president could just
say listen Rob Porter left there were
serious
allegations made against him end of
story and if they say what about the
allegations made against you he says I
don't know what happened with rod Porter
I do know what happened with me because
I was there I didn't do any of this
stuff now did he do some of the stuff
I'm sure Trump did some of this stuff
okay I said this during the campaign the
idea that Donald Trump was was is a man
of moral rectitude when it comes to the
treatment of women I think is belied by
his history I just don't think that's
the case does that mean he's a bad
president no does that mean that he's
doing a lot of stuff that I that I like
I mean he's doing a lot of stuff that I
like right again does that mean he
shouldn't no one should've ever voted
for him I'm not making that case I am
making the case that President Trump in
defending Rob Porter here by saying he's
innocent or he says he's innocent is
making really a case for himself and
that's not something pleasant and it is
it's not really about Trump it's about
you right what standard do you use for
evaluation of evidence I don't care
about what Trump does right Trump's the
President of the United States he's
there to do a job as either doing it or
he's not doing it I do think that it
degrades the moral standard when the
presidents of the United States makes
light of serious allegations but you how
do you do it because you can do both
things you can say Trump's a great
president you can love the guy but you
can say you love everything that he's
doing I like some of the things that
he's doing but it is still incumbent on
you to make a moral decision about what
behavior you're gonna tolerate and what
standard you hold people to and I'm not
even talking about Trump's behavior I'm
talking about Rob Porter's behavior if
you like Trump does that mean you have
to defend Trump's defensive Rob Porter I
don't think so I don't think so I think
that you are allowed to say what is bad
and what is good now instead of doing
that because people can't stand
cognitive dissonance
a bunch of members of the Trump
administration or former members of the
Trump administration are blaming
everybody except for except for John
Kelly who apparently knew about this and
let it go with Rob Porter and time again
the White House Counsel Sebastian gorica
the former member of the Trump
administration he came out he blamed the
CIA bureaucracy believe it or not I can
tell you I'm not going to name names but
we had some amazing candidates one of
them was supposed to come in to a senior
directors ship position in the National
Security Council and the people handling
the background clearances specifically
the CIA slow rolled it so there's an
issue of if they want to if they want to
gum up the works if they want to make
the Trump administrations who job harder
and harder they play bureaucratic slow
roles and and there may be a a
deliberate minefield put in place where
they know some
like this has skeletons in that closet
okay this is what I hate is that now the
deep state has become an excuse for
everything so John Kelly apparently knew
some stuff so - Don McGann and now we're
going to blame the deep state for
everything when you when you are blaming
something as the bogeyman for everything
that's always a dangerous business the
reality is people are responsible for
their actions okay should John Kelly be
ousted over the Rob Porter thing that's
up to president Trump okay didn't commit
a crime here but it's up to President
Trump to figure out whether Kelly has
compromised his administration to such
an extent that he should go my guess is
I doubt it is this a serious black mark
on Kelly's record I think that it is but
you know a black mark doesn't mean that
you necessarily have to leave the
administration that said Kelly should be
defending his behavior here there
there's another problem here - and that
other problem is that is that
Republicans feel compelled to say nice
things in front of President Trump
because they're afraid of alienating the
president because he is so thin-skinned
so for example Rand Paul came out and he
was struggling to avoid condemning
President Trump
that's no shock again I think that a lot
of Republicans are struggling to do this
that is not your job
okay President Trump is a big boy he's a
71 year old man he's fully capable of
accepting a little bit of heat for this
stuff and if he feels that you are
attacking him she strenuously that's
really on him it's really his problem I
don't think Republicans ought to ought
to discard their own moral standard in
favor of appeasing the president's
feelings okay in just a second I want to
talk about some of the worst portraits
in human history Plus Republicans
spending like drunken sailors but first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at wink
so yeah January's time for you to bring
yourself out from the holiday parties
but guess what now it's time for you to
relax again because the reality is
January is a tough month
hey January stuff - always tough at the
beginning of the year treat yourself go
over to wink
okay winc it's a great resource it makes
enjoying downtime that much easier
because now the wine is delivered
directly to your house and it is the
best wine okay wink makes it easy to
discover great wine if you want to go
over to somebody's house for dinner you
don't know what bottle of wine to bring
because you don't know anything about
why you don't know the difference
between a bottle of rubbing alcohol and
a decent wine that's why you need wink
because they have this algorithm you go
to their palate profile quiz and you
answer simple questions your average
store clerk wouldn't ask or translate
into a recommendation questions like how
do you like your coffee how do you feel
about blueberries and then they send you
wines curated to to your taste and the
more wines you rate the more
personalized or monthly selections
become each month there are new
delicious
they have an insanely popular summer
water Rosie has been tried by a lot of
folks around the office who really enjoy
it
shipping is covered if you don't like a
bottle they send you they replace it
with the bottle that you do love no
questions asked so discover great wine
today go to try wink calm / Ben let's
try winc calm / Ben you have 20 bucks
off your first shipment thanks great
Valentine's Day gift by the way getting
a subscription to wink so if you're want
your your loved one to to have a
wonderful year they're just enjoying a
new bottle of wine every every month no
membership fees skip any month cancel
anytime go to try wink calm / menu get
$20 off your first shipment that's gry
winc calm / Ben for 20 bucks off try
wink calm / Ben go check it out remember
to use that / Ben for the $20 off and
also so they know that we sent you okay
so well I you know I would break on
Facebook normally but I'm not going to
because I definitely want to show you
these these actual graphics it would be
a pity not to do this visually so over
at the at the Smithsonian they have the
National Portrait Gallery the National
Portrait Gallery has pictures of all the
presidents and pictures of all of the
first ladies and they have now unveiled
the pictures for Barack and Michelle
Obama so here is the picture of Barack
Obama you see there on the left there is
Barack Obama and he is actually sitting
there in a chair that's apparently
covered by leaves he's getting poison
ivy he's being eaten by it is like
Little Shop of Horrors he's actually
being eaten by the foliage and looking
very serious and of course this
immediately made me think of Homer
Simpson backing into the bushes that is
not of course the best version of this
Shoshana Weissman over on Twitter had
the best version of this of this
portrait here's what it looked like yeah
there it is makes perfect sense because
the truth is that aside from Obama's
talk the president the United States was
not a particularly useful guy
particularly on foreign policy he did
not forward the ball on foreign policy
he sort of sat there while people got
slaughtered in Syria sat there while
Iran developed a nuclear program you
know sat there while Israel was under
siege sat there during the Arab Spring
sat there is riots happened in major
American cities so that's actually a
pretty good likeness of President Obama
you know I think that's that's not a bad
portrait of the president it's so funny
you know they're always saying we have
to do something creative with the
portraits very important we do something
creative so the artists said something
about
we wanted to show that Obama's
presidency was was he the form figure or
was he just being swallowed by history
was he the driver of history or was he
just a representative of it and then
apparently the various flowers here are
signified flowers from Kenya and flowers
from Hawaii and flowers from Chicago I
don't know what the flower from Chicago
is I assume that it's the opium poppy
but the idea that Barack Obama is
sitting there in Wrigley's IV in Wrigley
fields IV is really weird he's a Sox fan
and supposedly he's not really a Sox fan
by the way they one of my pet peeves as
I've mentioned many times over I am a
true White Sox fan Barack Obama could
not name one single player on the White
Sox when he was interviewed during his
2008 presidential run the real fan he is
okay so that was the picture of Obama
that one was getting mocked pretty
relentlessly that one is not the worst
the worst one is of Michelle so here's
the picture of Michelle Obama okay does
that look anything like Michelle Obama
of course it doesn't look like anything
like Michelle Obama it looks like Regina
King right the actress it doesn't look
like Michelle Obama at all and so people
were making fun of this people are
getting a big kick out of the fact that
the portraits don't look like anything
so naturally all the lefties came out
defending the portrait they're not
supposed to look like the people they
said really this was one of the lines
that these portraits were supposed to be
artistic they're not just supposed to
look like the people well then why don't
you just put a Kandinsky up there all
right now why just put a Jackson Pollock
up there you feel like a splash of paint
and say this represents Michelle Obama
there's no like anything like Michelle
Obama this is one of my is one of my
favorite things in the world by the way
is when people do terrible portraits and
terrible statues as you were recall I'm
a huge fan of the Cristiano Ronaldo
statue one of my favorite statues of all
time where he looks like a demented
demon sent from Hell to torment people
there's a statue of Harry Caray that's
just spectacular outside Wrigley Field
where it looks like they're a bunch of
faces that are clawing their way out of
Hades in order to be lectured about the
the fortunes of the Cubs by Harry Carey
there's a great one of Walter Johnson
where they tried to make it look like
his arm was in motion and instead it
just looks like hell spawn because his
arm is actually like coming out of his
body in five different ways it's pretty
spectacular son ranks pretty high up
there it's like Lucille Ball statue that
looks nothing like Lucille Ball so well
done National Portrait Gallery and
congratulations again to Regina King for
her portrait being entered into the
National Gallery it's very exciting
congratulations to Homer Simpson as well
for for being hidden in that picture of
Barack Obama
so all of that is very exciting so in
unless wonderfulness it now turns out
that the oath at the Trump
administration wants to spend orals and
oodles and oodles of money so today they
offered their budget plan it is a four
point four trillion dollar budget plan
yes indeedy-do four point four trillion
dollars that means it carries nearly a
trillion dollar deficit each of the next
few years just awesome I remember when
we were the party of fiscal
responsibility yeah that lasted for five
seconds one of the fun things about
being a Republican apparently is he gets
to scream about fiscal responsibility
until the point you get elected and
which point you just blow out the
spending so according to the Washington
Post President Trump on Monday was gonna
offer this budget plan it falls far
short of eliminating the government's
deficit over 10 years conceding that
huge tax cuts and new spending increases
make this goal unattainable three people
familiar with the proposal said
eliminating the budget deficit over ten
years has been a North Star for the
Republican Party for several decades and
GOP lawmakers took the government to the
brink of default in 2011 demanding a
vote on an amendment to the Constitution
that prohibit the federal government
from spending more than it takes in that
was something the Democrats used to back
to now turns out everybody's a liar
House Speaker Paul Ryan who's a fiscal
conservative supposedly when he used to
take chair of the House Budget Committee
routinely proposed tax and spending
outlines that would eliminate the
deficit over ten years even though
critics said that this would lead to a
severe curtailment in government
programs because in order for you to
actually fix the programs that means
that you have to restructure Medicaid
Medicare Social Security instead we're
actually expending Medicaid we're
expanding at Medicare and we are
expanding Social Security apparently in
the new budget in 2013 Paul Ryan
proposed four point six trillion dollars
in cuts over ten years in amount he said
was sufficient to eliminate the deficit
those changes were not adopted by
Congress or supported by the Obama
administration but now it turns out
Republicans don't care after all how
exciting they've now jettison goals like
this since Trump took office
Trump's budget plan calls for a range of
spending cuts reducing the growth of the
deficit by three trillion dollars over
ten years it would not eliminate the
deficit entirely said people familiar
with the proposal so what exactly does
it include apparently it includes a
bunch of new spending on infrastructure
particularly they are now putting forth
a they're not putting forth a 1.5 to
trillion dollar infrastructure budget
that would include two hundred billion
dollars of American taxpayer money being
spent on infrastructure one of the
things that's always puzzled me about
this infrastructure argue
it is why not just involve it to the
states why not make it California's
responsibility to do I'll keep on its
own roads the idea that you needed in
the national highway structure that you
needed the Eisenhower's national highway
system is not true and hardcore
libertarians will tell you this the fact
is that route 66 I've said this before
on the program route 66 which NAT can
call use to sing about right get your
kicks on Route 66 that used to be a
thing because it was a state highway
connected with another state highway
then we built the the interstate highway
system when the interstate highway
system supposedly made travel that much
more convenient but it made all of these
towns ghost towns because they were no
longer serving state interests they were
now serving supposedly federal interests
it was a boondoggle we spent an awful
lot of money on the national highway
system listen I enjoy driving on the
highways as much as the next guy but the
idea that it wouldn't have existed
without States is just not true there
are state highway systems and they just
would have connected to one another so
where are these cuts supposed to take
place well the budget is expected to
target spending cuts and social welfare
programs like Medicaid and the
supplemental nutritional assistance
program may that's nap that's the that's
food stamps the White House is looking
at ways to curb these programs by
expanding work requirements for
beneficiaries it's unclear how much it
changes like this would actually spend
and then their spending increases as
well two hundred billion in federal
funds I mentioned before the
infrastructure plan twenty three billion
dollars for border security and
immigration enforcement none of that's
going to happen eighty five point five
billion for veterans programs thirteen
billion over the next two years to
combat the opioid epidemic if you want
to combat the opioid epidemic then you
actually should curb Medicaid one of the
big problems that they've had is that
everywhere that Medicaid has expanded
opioid addiction has expanded because
Medicaid actually covers the ability to
get cheap yet cheap opioid painkillers
this is there have been several studies
that been done on this particular point
bottom line is the Trump is blowing at
the budget now the media's coverage of
this is always really interesting
because they suggest that this is the
end of the world that he's blowing out
the budget first of all this budget is
not going to pass
second of all the Democrats used to
routinely proposed budgets like this
just as big and the media never covered
it this way the media always covered
these budget busting budget busting
budgets as something fine and decent
it's never a big deal they they're gonna
spend as much as they possibly can no
biggie at all it's still not good for
Republicans that we are proposing this
kind of spending and demonstrative of
fact
publicans have been lying about this
stuff for years the budget calls for 716
billion dollars in defense spending in
2019 in order to rebuild the military
and again it includes that
trillion-dollar infrastructure program
the White House budget assumes economic
growth will accelerate from 2.3 percent
last year to 3 percent this year and 3.2
percent next year spurred on by the tax
cut we will see if that is true or not
even with that assumption of robust
economic growth the federal deficit is
expected to increase for it to 4 to hit
4.2 percent of GDP this year and 4.7
percent next year its usual as they note
for the deficit to increase during
recessions it is not usual for the
deficit to increase during peacetime non
recessions and that's exactly what is
happening here so once again this
demonstrates this this bizarre notion in
the American public mind that we like to
cut spending when we don't actually like
to cut spending right we don't actually
like cutting spending we like to pretend
that we like cutting spending then as
soon as someone says well I guess we're
gonna have to cut something then
everybody protests and goes totally
crazy over it ok in other news
apparently the sorry quick quick note
there are Republicans who are butting
back against this will see a Paul Ryan
does Jim Jordan one of our favorite
Congress people from Ohio he came out
and he said that the spending increases
that were included in the major spending
bill that was passed last week by the
house this is unsustainable you asked me
if he has if yet if there's concerns
with the speaker I think they're big
concerns because he just presided over
one of the biggest spending increases in
the history of this country at a time
when we were elected to do just the
opposite okay that of course is exactly
true okay in other news it looks like
Israel is drawing closer to a possible
war with Iran over the weekend in news
that has gone largely ignored except on
Drudge Report Israel issued stark
warnings on Sunday over Iran's president
in neighboring Syria after a
confrontation threatened to open a new
and unpredictable period in the
country's seven-year Civil War Israel
carried out major raids on Syria on
Saturday including against what it
described as reining in targets in Iran
has been using Syria as a thoroughfare
to smuggle weapons over to the
terrorists Hezbollah in Lebanon the
raids came after after an Israeli f-16
fighter was shot down by Syrian air
defenses that was the first Israeli
plane shot down since 1982 the pilots
were okay they ejected safely but they
were still yeah obviously the Syrian
forces were still should they still shot
down
in Israeli in Israeli plane an f-16
fighter which is scary stuff Prime
Minister Netanyahu said we inflicted on
Saturday a heavy blow to Iranian and
Syrian forces we made it clear to
everyone our rules of engagement will
not change in any way we will continue
to harm anyone who tries to harm us this
is our policy this will remain our
policy other Israeli ministers spoke of
refusing to accept and entrenching
itself militarily in Syria as Netanyahu
has said repeatedly Tehran denies that
it is doing so there's one of the holes
in the the Trump administration policies
in Syria if Iran fills the gap in Syria
and in dangers American allies not just
in Israel but in Jordan in Saudi Arabia
in Egypt all of those countries know it
and so the more that Iran exercises and
flexes its muscle the more those
countries are going to be forced to take
military action in response that's not
Trump's fault
right he picked up a bad situation in
Syria that's Obama's fault now picture
of Obama receding into the bushes even
that is a little too generous for
Obama's policy on Iran which was not
receding into the bushes
it was absolutely handing Iran pathway
to a nuclear bomb as well as regional
power and that has serious consequences
including for our allies over in Israel
and not just in Israel but also in
Jordan and Saudi Arabia in Egypt
Saturday's events began with Israel's
shooting down when it's described as an
Iranian drone that had entered Israeli
airspace from Syria Tehran tonight it on
Sunday Israeli military spokesman
Jonathan Cahn Rica's alleged that the
drone was a copy of the u.s. model
captured by Iran in 2011 he said the
conclusion was made from analysis of the
drones of the drones at debris so they
were using a the Iranians were using a
drone to try and scout out Israeli
airspace Israel respond with the f-16
that was shot down so things are
escalating quickly over there we will
keep an eye on it as it develops okay so
we are now going to be some things I
like in things I hate but first you're
gonna have to go over and subscribe over
at daily wire comm $9.99 a month gets
you a subscription to daily wire.com
when you get that you get the rest of my
show live you get the rest mandrill
Clavin show live you get the rest of
Michael Noel's waffle show live also if
you really love Michael moles that much
if you really love that guy well
Valentine's Day is coming up so you and
Michael moles sitting in a tree kis s
ing or re ad ing emails to one another
because this Wednesday February 14th 5
p.m. Eastern the lonely desperate
pathetic Michael Noel's will be
literally waiting for your questions in
our next episode of the conversation yes
he's been thrown out of his home and
he'll have nothing to do for Valentine's
Day and that's why he will be here
streaming live on Facebook YouTube in
the Daily wire website it's free forever
to watch only subscribers can join the
website and ask the questions to ask
questions as a subscriber log in to our
website at daily wire.com head over to
the conversation page and watch the live
stream after that start typing into the
daily wired chat box Michael will answer
live questions as they come in for an
entire hour and may contain references
while smoking a cigar and hopefully
wearing pants once again subscribe to
get your questions answered by Michael
moles this Valentine's Day on Wednesday
February 14th at 5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m.
Pacific if you hate Valentine's Day and
you find it egregious and insufferable
make it even worse by joining Michael
moles with the conversation at 5 p.m.
Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific and become a
subscriber so you can ask some questions
if you want the annual subscription you
get all of those things Plus this the
leftist here is hot or cold temblor it
is delightful it is spectacular it is
refreshing magnificent magnificent so
check that out when you get the annual
subscription for $99 year it is cheaper
than the monthly subscription so save
yourself some money and make yourself
intellectually richer by doing so check
us out later for free over at SoundCloud
iTunes YouTube please subscribe to our
YouTube channel where the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like so there is a so
there's a group called the network of
enlightened women and they're doing
something where they honor gentlemen
they have a contest they calling it the
gentlemen showcase and they honored me
last they honored me this month in the
month of February which is very nice of
them they called me their honorary
gentleman which I really appreciate
see I don't care about the idea of being
tough and rough and tumble as you may
have noticed that's not my thing but I
do care about being a gentleman because
I think the gentlemen are people who
understand that women and children are
to be protected innocence in supera is
to be protected and good principles are
worth fighting for so go over and check
them out an enlightened women that's
their Facebook page and I have an
interview over there about what it means
to to be a man and what I suggested that
we should stop criticizing manliness we
should start talking instead about what
manliness actually is so check out the
network of enlightened women over at
their Facebook page because they were
nice enough to give me an award and
therefore I will pump them because I'm
just that kind of person okay time for a
couple of things that well sorry you
know one more thing that I like there's
a good book out by a guy named David ban
s'en it's called crisis of
responsibility I should check that out
David Banton is on board over at
National Review he's on the board of
several other organizations the Ford has
been my good friend David French and the
book is essentially a treatise on why it
is that Americans are avoiding their
problems by pointing at one another and
and trying to cast responsibility for
mistakes on one another if we could get
rid of that of that capacity to blame
one another and take some responsibility
for ourselves we do a lot better in life
that's the theme of the book check it
out crisis of responsibility by David
Sampson okay time for a couple of things
that I hate so Robert DeNiro was over in
the United Arab Emirates and there he
was ripping in the United States because
this is what we do we praise North Korea
and we rip the United States Hollywood
star Robert De Niro according to page
six took aim at the Trump
administration's stance on climate
change
telling a packed audience in the middle
east that he was visiting from a
backward country suffering from
temporary insanity which is something
that I definitely want to hear from the
star of Meet the Fockers that's that's
clearly something that I think is deeply
important he said in the country he's
describing in the head of the
Environmental Protection Agency
suggested last week global warming may
be a good
for Humanity he said I'm talking about
my own country the United States of
America we don't like to say we're a
backward country so let's just say we're
suffering from a case of temporary
insanity and he receives applause and
laughs when he said the US will
eventually care itself by voting our
dangerous leader out of office he spoke
Sunday to by his world government summit
there's certain irony Tim speaking in
one of the leads one of the world's
leading producers of oil UNITA vera
United Arab Emirates their entire wealth
base is oil it's why the the the GDP per
capita in UAE is extraordinarily high
and there he is jabbering about global
warming and dangers of it and one of the
leading oil producers on planet earth
and then ripping the United States for
our supposed craziness over global
warming in a country that regularly
represses women does not allow Israelis
to visit as far as I'm aware and and is
a backward country in a ton of cultural
respect does he say any of that of
course not he goes there and he kisses
their button he talked about terrible
Trump as again for the left the enemy of
their enemy is their friend and that
means that they're supposed enemy in the
UAE is not their enemy at all these
people are friends because they don't
like Donald Trump so long as they don't
like Donald Trump that means they're
wonderful wonderful human beings which
is just the worst moral code I can I can
imagine okay other things that I hate so
a 42 year old man who's now married his
daughter and he was arrested for it so
according to Frank camp over at Daily
wire a Virginia man and his 20 year old
biological daughter faced incest charges
after having a child together
Eve in 1998 Stephen Walter plateau and
his then wife gave their daughter Katie
Platt all up for adoption approximately
eighteen years later Katie found her
birth parents using social media by
August 2016 she was living with a couple
and their other biological children in
their Virginia home and that according
to Warren's Stephen played ell and his
wife legally separated in November 2016
and the wife moved out plateaus wife
claimed her husband and be done sleeping
on the floor in Katie's room prior to
her vacating the home in May 2017 though
I've discovered that Stephen had
impregnated Katie according to WNCN TV
she then confronted Stephen and admitted
that he and Katie had been involved in a
sexual relationship
resulting in the conception of a child
and on July 21st
there was an Instagram post showing a
pregnant daughter with her biological
father saying that they were married now
which is just horrifying now I have a
question for folks on the left and
cultural libertarians why is it
horrifying really why is it horrifying
for advocates of same-sex marriage for
example
why is this particularly horrifying and
don't give me all this stuff about
two-headed babies it's quite possible if
the baby won't be two-headed it's
possible the baby will be healthy and
let's suggest for just a second that you
are infertile would that make the
situation any better see according to
the left the only thing that matters
when it comes to sexual relationships is
the value of consent so if both parties
are consenting did something truly
terrible happen here one of the things
that's very interesting about the way
human morality works Jonathan Hite
points this out in his book the
righteous mind is that there are several
different variables that we use to
determine our morality one of those
variables that is completely ignored by
the left is the value of purity the idea
that there is something to the human
soul that is schmutz stop right there's
something to the human soul that is
dirtied by activities like incest if
there's just something inherently wrong
with incest we know that it's wrong we
can't necessarily explain why and that's
okay there are certain things that are
just bad right the left refuses to abide
by this and forget about whether it
should be illegal or not on a
libertarian level think about whether it
is morally wrong
so Jonathan Hite starts his book talking
about you know various different various
different kind of gross things that
people could do the cultural
libertarians would say was okay like
having sex with a dead body for example
right is that something terrible so you
say it's terrible I say it's terrible
cultural libertarians cultural leftist
they would say what's so terrible about
it body doesn't need consent it's an
inanimate object that materialist so
what's the big deal so Jonathan Hyde
suggests that there are six foundations
to moral theory care which is the
protecting people from harm fairness or
proportionality which is you know what
it sounds like rendering justice to
people both the left and right agree on
these then there are a bunch of things
that the left and right do not
necessarily agree on Liberty is the is
the loathing of tyranny which may or may
not be something left believes in
loyalty in-group loyalty but has
something left doesn't seem to care very
much about it's something that the right
cares about but should care about an
ideological level more than they care
about on a biological level Authority or
respect the idea there's an inherent
value to respecting your elders for
example because they may know something
that you don't that's something the Left
doesn't agree with and sanctity or
purity abhorrence for disgusting things
the idea that you are more than just a
collection of your body parts this is
something left doesn't agree with either
so before you start condemning
the daughter and the father who got
married and had a baby and you on the
Left you need to examine what are your
moral principles and maybe you think
that it's totally fine if you do think
it's fine then maybe you should consider
whether you are fine
whether that is actually a proper moral
standard to hold okay now quickly it's
Monday so we go through a federalist
paper we are on federalist 15 we are
steadily making our way through the
Federalist Papers Federalist 15 is
written by Alexander Hamilton this
Federalist paper lays forth the problems
of the Articles of confederacy so
they've already established why they
think America ought to be one country
believe that America ought not be split
among various different countries now
they have to explain why the articles of
the Confederacy isn't enough that was
the system of law that pervade prior to
the Constitution of the United States it
led to some serious problems like the
shays rebellion it led to some serious
problems with regard to particular armed
insurrection with regards to the
inability of the government to pay off
its own debts and that's what Hamilton
says he says we may indeed with
propriety be said to have reached almost
last stage of natural national
humiliation there's scarcely anything
that can move the pride or degrade the
character of an independent nation which
we do not experience so what's he upset
about
he's upset we haven't kept our
agreements abroad we owe debts we
haven't driven people off land they've
already surrendered to us we don't have
control of the Mississippi River our
public credit is dead he says the
problem here is lack of federal capacity
right if you don't have any centralized
power at all they don't have the power
of enforcement it's going to be
extremely difficult for you to actually
be able to enforce America's interests
at the national level he says that what
the federal government needs is the
power of coercion he says government
implies the power of making laws it is
essential to the idea of a law that it
be attended with a sanction or in other
words a penalty or punishment for
disobedience if there be no penalty
annexed to disobedience the resolutions
or commands which pretend to be laws
will in fact amount to nothing more than
advice or recommendation now there's a
flipside to this idea if government is
coercion that means that government
should be used very sparingly and this
is something the founders understood as
well so while they're calling for more
centralization of power there is a happy
medium where the government needs the
power to coerce in cases where the
government is protecting life liberty
and property in other cases the
government is a big gun it is a giant
killing people machine a giant
imprisoning people machine a giant
enforcement machine the government is a
coercion machine and therefore it has to
be you sparingly and we have to be very
careful about where we give the
government the power of the sword and
where we do not ok we will be back here
tomorrow with all the latest news
updates I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing